actually Tim I wish him well we have
many many political differences but
notwithstanding those I'll do my very
best to build a constructive working
relationship with him I think it is
notable and I think it's important to
say this that he is the first British
Indian indeed the first from a South
Asian Heritage to become Prime Minister
that is important regardless of politics
and whether or not they vote
conservative there will be many British
Indians Asians that are looking at his
appointment as prime minister and
thinking that that is significant and
important and it is you know I would say
two things in terms of early decisions
firstly he should call an early general
election he's the second person in a row
to be appointed as prime minister by
Tories Not Elected by the population the
idea that he can go two years before
seeking or winning a democratic mandate
I think is just Unthinkable and secondly
he absolutely should not unleash another
wave of austerity you know our Public
Services the Scottish government's
budget we're still dealing with the
legacy of the first wave of Tony
austerity right now dealing with the
problem of sorting inflation our Public
Services cannot withstand another round
of Tory austerity so big political
differences uh for Scotland of course he
has no mandate he hasn't been elected
probably wouldn't be elected in Scotland
even if we were given the chance just
another prime minister with no
Democratic legitimacy here in Scotland
but does he have any choice but to look
at cuts to Public Services the
alternative to that is presumably more
borrowing or indeed higher taxes but and
I I'm guessing you don't really think
either of those are the solution like
well I don't think we should be trapped
into this story and actually labor
mindset that there's no alternative to
this you know economic Mayhem it's been
caused by brexit and I think there is a
real need for Rishi sunak who of course
was a brexit here to face up to that
brexit is doing the economy real damage
and of course that's been compounded in
recent weeks by the decisions that list
trust to that have you know brought the
UK economy to its needs so let's get
some common sense back and actually
start dealing with the root causes of
this because having this choice between
Tori austerity and and more borrowing or
tax Rises is one that's been imposed
Upon Us by the economic decision making
of the Tories but what is beyond any
doubt is that public services I don't
think can cope with another round of
austerity you know they are still
dealing with the legacy of the last
round of Tory imposed austerity and it
will be existential for public services
to some extent and also people
businesses families across the country
already dealing with the cost of living
crisis cannot withstand this so it's
time for a fundamental rethink and I
think at one of the big tests of Rishi
sunak in his first hours and certainly
days in office is whether he is capable
of doing that fundamental rethink and
admitting some very basic home truths
for the conservatives top of that list
brexit has been an economic disaster and
we're within independent Scotland get
the money to avoid public service cuts
uh look we will inherit it as an
independent country at the fiscal
position of the UK of Scotland as part
of the UK as I set out last week uh we
will take a different approach to
dealing with that you know I said last
week plans for example for a building a
new Scotland fund which is focused on
infrastructure investment Scotland's a
wealthy country we have amazing
resources not least our renewable energy
resources so dealing with the fiscal
situation we inherit in a humane way in
a civilized way in a way that protects
public services and gets the economy
growing based on our sustainable
resources is the week to do it not
another round of austerity and again
let's not get caught and perhaps this is
a message to Media as well as to
politicians here let's not get caught
trapped in this Tory mindset of there is
no alternative we see labor getting
caught in that right now accepting that
there is no way of reversing brexit
there is a way of reversing brexit for
Scotland if we choose to take it it
doesn't have to be like this we can do
better than this and Rishi sunak has
said there needs to be more scrutiny of
your government here in Scotland what do
you think of that I don't think if I can
say this very very gently I'm going to
take any lessons from Rishi sunak or any
Tori right now about Democratic scrutiny
you know I've been first Minister for
just short of eight years I've lost
count of the number of Elections I've
laid my party to victory in and of
course rightly I'm subjected to scrutiny
each and every day through the Scottish
Parliament so I think it's probably a
time for the conservatives to look
themselves in the mirror when it comes
to democratic accountability and
scrutiny and I'll continue to be
accountable to and scrutinize by
Scotland's democratically elected
Parliament and above all by the people
of Scotland and just finally Rishi sunak
has also made it clear that like his
predecessors he does not think nor would
he agree to there being another
referendum on Independence what is your
reaction to that well it's not foreign
becomes independent or not of course we
await the outcome of the Supreme Court
reference and that will tell us whether
or not the Scottish Parliament has the
the competence to legislate for a
referendum I hope the outcome of that is
that the Scottish Parliament does in
which case there'll be a referendum next
year if that is not the outcome then
we'll take the issue to the people in an
election uh Scottish democracy cannot be
and will not be the prisoner of Rishi
sunach or frankly any Westminster prime
minister